in the last video we discussed
Christopher Columbus's attempt to find
the funding to find a Western route
around the world to China and the East
and how although he didn't find that in
October of 1492 he landed in the
Caribbean where he met the indigenous
people living there the Tainos so who
were the Tainos so we know a little bit
about them they were one of the
indigenous peoples and the Caribbean
this is a woodcut that depicts people in
the region made a little bit later so
they may have looked something like this
and they were adept at fishing we know
that they were probably matrilineal that
is they traced their family lines
through the women not the men we know
that they were very generous people
Columbus repeatedly describes how people
would really give you anything that you
asked for we also know religiously that
they worshiped ancestor spirits called
zimmy's and this is a statue of one of
those ancestor spirits that we still
have today another thing I think is
really cool about the Tainos is that we
still use some of their words in
everyday language that were borrowed by
the Spanish and then came in to English
so barbeque for example they called
barbacoa hurricanes they called
hurricane tobacco was one of their words
for the plant that will become so
popular even the name of the island
itself they called it a et which is
still preserved today in the nation of
Haiti
so Columbus sailed around the Caribbean
and then he made his way back to Europe
he left behind him 39 men whose ship had
run aground so they built a fort and
when he arrived in Europe he immediately
wrote a letter to the finance minister
to Ferdinand and Isabella Louis de Sant
Angele so let's look a little bit more
close
Liat what he wrote as I know you will be
rejoiced to the glorious success that
our Lord has given me in my voyage I
write this to tell you how in 33 days I
sailed to the Indies with the fleet that
the illustrious km Queen our sovereigns
gave me where I discovered a great many
islands inhabited by numberless people
and of all I have taken possession for
their Highnesses by proclamation and
display of the royal standard without
opposition to the first island I gave
the name of San Salvador in
commemoration of His divine majesty the
second I named the island of Santa Maria
de concepción the third Fernandina the
fourth isabella the fifth Juana and I
found it so extensive that I thought it
might be the mainland the province of
Caffe this is really interesting because
you can tell a lot about what Columbus
is thinking here first he says that he's
taken possession of these islands by
proclamation and display of the royal
standard without opposition and I love
this image of Columbus he's reading in
Spanish the proclamation I claim this
land in the name of Spain and he's not
opposed because the Tainos have no idea
what he's saying can also see his
religious motivations here as he names
the first islands after sin Salvador the
Savior Jesus Santa Maria de concepción
the Virgin Mary and that he's trying to
win some points with Ferdinand and
Isabella by naming islands after them
you can also see here that Columbus
thinks that he's found China he says he
thought it might be the mainland the
province of cafe cafe is an old word
meaning China so let's read on he says I
began fortifications there which should
be completed by this time and I have
left in it men enough to hold it with
arms artillery and provisions for more
than a year and a boat with a master
seaman's skilled in the arts necessary
to make others I am so friendly with the
king of that country that he was proud
to call me his brother and hold me as
such even should he change his mind and
wish to quarrel neither he nor his
subjects know what arms are nor wear
clothes as I have said they're the most
timid people in the world so that only
the men remaining there could destroy
the whole region so he's kind of saying
that we're getting along with the
natives but if we don't the
not a threat he finishes by saying to
speak in conclusion only of what has
been done during this hurried voyage
their Highnesses will see that I can
give them as much gold as they desire if
they will give me a little assistance
spices cotton as much as their
Highnesses may command to be shipped and
as many slaves as they choose to send
for all heathens so Columbus is
finishing by saying well this
exploratory voyage has shown that we can
get a lot out of colonizing this area we
can get gold spices cotton slaves and so
if you will give me a little assistance
that is give me more resources to
continue my mission Spain will get very
wealthy indeed from this new land and
that is exactly what Ferdinand and
Isabella do so they sent him on a second
voyage in 1493 and this time they send
him with 1200 men and 17 ships and they
bring with them
livestock horses cattle pigs and
sugarcane plants they can turn this into
a plantation so they really intend to
use this settlement as not only a place
to try out growing crops and also mining
for gold they also see it as kind of a
jumping-off place that they can use for
further exploration in this area because
the Portuguese were so dominant in this
early phase of colonialism the Spanish
are nervous that the Portuguese are
going to try to make inroads into their
new acquisitions in the West so with the
help of the Pope they negotiate what's
called the Treaty of Tordesillas
dividing the world between them so east
of this line here this will be
Portugal's area of the world and west of
this line will be Spain's remember that
Portugal had lots of interests in Africa
which they thought were much more
valuable at this time but it was later
discovered that part of South America
fell on Portugal's side of the line and
you'll recognize that
being today Brazil which became a
Portuguese colony and even today speaks
Portuguese now of course they didn't ask
anybody else's permission to divide the
world between them they didn't ask the
native people of the Americas they
didn't ask anybody else in Europe but
it's important to understand that Spain
thought of this area as their sovereign
territory and from this point forward
Spain will continue to send what are
called conquistadors conquerors to this
region Mexico and Florida and South
America and from all of this they will
become very wealthy as a nation so I
just want to finish by contrasting how
Columbus's voyage affected the native
people of the Caribbean with how it
affected Europe so Columbus was not very
nice to the natives in fact he
originally attempted to enslave the
native people and send them back to
Europe for sale to continue to
underwrite his ventures but they were
susceptible to European diseases and
quickly died so he had to take another
tack and that was by forcing the native
people to labor for the Spanish
particularly to mine gold
and not long after Columbus returned he
put a quota for all people over the age
of 14 that they had to give him a
certain amount of gold per month or they
would have their hands chopped off and
this is an engraving of what the Spanish
were imagined to have been like in the
new world you can see that they're
feeding children to dogs here they were
not quite as bad as this but they were
still pretty bad historians estimate
that there were about one to three
million Tainos living in the Caribbean
when the Spanish arrived by a hundred
years later there were 200 left not
200,000 200
and mostly this was due to disease and
we'll talk more in the next video about
why Native people seem to be so
susceptible to European diseases but it
was also due to overwork and poor
treatment they were forced to mine when
they should have been growing crops and
many of them were murdered by the
Spanish for one reason or another so for
the people of the Caribbean Columbus's
arrival was really a catastrophe in
Europe however the new world made Spain
very rich and the gold and silver being
brought in from the new world to Spain
may actually have increased prices in
the 100 years following Columbus's
voyage by 500 to 600 percent due to
inflation
thanks to gold from the new world
some historians even think that the
influx of all this new wealth led to the
creation of the modern banking system to
deal with it and could even have been
the forbear of capitalism so Columbus's
voyage really opened up a whole new
world not just to the people in the
Americas but also to the people in
Europe he started a process the
Columbian Exchange we'll talk more about
that in the next video